hier soir le conseil de sécurité de
l'onu a adopté une résolution pour
garantir les conditions de départ des
afghans mais rien sur la mise en place
d'une zone protégée à à kaboul comme le
demandait le royaume uni et la france
emmanuel macron c'est d'ailleurs a
exprimé à ce propos c'était dimanche
dernier ont fait le point sur cette
résolution avec notre reporter nadège
abderrazak devant les listes
la france et le royaume uni voulait une
zone protégée en afghanistan pour
pouvoir continuer à évacuer après le 31
août et le départ des troupes
américaines c'est manquer s'ils n'ont
pas trouvé le soutien espéré de la part
de l'onu alors ce qu'a fait le conseil
de sécurité des nations unies hier c'est
adopter une résolution
gravant dans le marbre les engagements
des talibans faveur du départ sur de
ceux qui veulent quitter l'afghanistan
alors pas de zone protégée à proprement
parler mais un passage sur l elysée s'en
satisfait tout de même nous avons obtenu
ce que nous demandions à savoir ce qu'il
fallait pour que l'aéroport soit un lieu
sûr pour ceux qui veulent quitter kaboul
selon la résolution le conseil de
sécurité réaffirme l'importance du
respect des droits humains notamment
ceux des femmes des enfants et des
minorités l'encouragent la mise en place
d'une résolution politique inclusive
avec la participation significative des
femmes le conseil demande également que
le territoire afghan ne soit pas utilisé
pour menacer ou attaquer d'autres pays
ou encore d'abriter des terroristes
voilà ce que l'on pouvait dire sur cette
résolution des nations unies qui s'est
tenue hier sur l'afghanistan alors que
l'armée américaine a d'ores et déjà
quitté le territoire afghan